California why haven't you left yet why
are you still in California this is
where I'm from my friends are there my
my church is there my memories are there
um and frankly if you live in California
you bought a home say in the 80s you're
doing very very well your house house is
appreciated like crazy uh I got a lot of
equity in my in my hes so I'm living
living quite well as long as I avoid the
homeless people and the uh in the
needles and yeah I'm serious about that
live in a very nice place in Hollywood
Hills I could go maybe to or three
blocks and on either side of the street
are a bunch of Vans full of people who
should yeah Hollywood Hills shouldn't be
living there um there's a really real
bad homeless problem in in the area
where I live um Antonio Rosa by the way
after the recall was over said I've
never seen La look so dirty I've never
seen so much homelessness he didn't say
anything during the recall but he said
it afterwards uh it's it's pretty
pathetic um and the Bay Area is even
worse what happened to it I mean for a
guy that's been there your entire life I
liveed there 24 years Vinnie lived there
I don't know how many years Tom you
lived there how many years 40 40 years
so we're all California natives he's a
Florida guy he's actually an Addison guy
Addison Texas guy born and raised in
Addison Texas Miami but but
I by way of Addison yeah yeah he's
that's trolling me the the evolution of
this great state that every the
California Dreaming right everybody M
and Papas everybody wanted to go to this
place what happened to
it single party government Democrats uh
Democrats control the assembly the
Senate they have two-third majority
Republicans need not even show up for
work they pass one job killing bill
after another one Freedom sapping bill
after another they're in bed with the
teachers union they're in bed with the
environmentalists uh and they've just
passed one law after another that's
undermining the middle class very
wealthy people can survive very poor
people can survive it's the middle class
people who are leaving and and uh and
lar the average price of a home in in
California is 175% above the national
average think about that the number one
reason that people site for leaving is
they cannot afford to buy a house and
they have no idea why they just know
they can't afford to buy one that's why
when people leave California go to
places like Colorado and Arizona uh they
start changing those States because they
still vote Democrat because they haven't
connected the dots hold on they still
vote Democrat when they leave the state
they haven't connected the dot they
don't they don't know why all they know
is that things are not I I can't I can't
get the kind of lifestyle that I want I
can get a better lifestyle in this state
that state that state but they have no
idea why well they're just attributing
it to the cost of living that's it or or
or whatever and how much is the average
house in California compared to the
national uh I think the average price of
a home in California is about 800,000
yep 741 look that I didn't even see that
I did it already are you impressed are
you impressed to back up what Larry's
talking about go take a look at the
history of Colorado Phoenix and Austin
excuse me Denver Phoenix and Austin
that's exactly what he's talking about
where they move in and they turn red to
Lavender and then blue I figured it'd be
the exact opposite people leaving
California being like I can't take the
restrictions I can't take the taxes I
can't take the regulation the
homelessness everything just combined
it's like I'm out of here I'm going to
go live my life I'm an independent
thinker and move to a state where I can
just do me but you're basically saying
no they're just going to continue their
left leaning policies even in in some
time Austin they have indoctrinated
people in California to believe
Republicans are just bad people go uh
and anything Republican is bad I mean
we're I'm I'm pro-life therefore I'm
anti-woman that's how that's that's how
they phrase it um I believe taxes are
too high therefore I'm for the rich I
mean that's what they do and they have
they have indoctrinated a whole
generation of of of people young people
in California to feel that way let me
ask this question Tom this goes to you
and uh to Larry so do do you think uh
you know we had teachers protesting
against the S this year and they're
saying you know Florida anti- Woka
agenda is causing us to want to leave
the state of Florida and you know some
people in Florida are like great go to
California Right Where You Belong yeah
so so do you do you think more uh uh
Democrats are leaving red States because
they can no longer be there and they're
finding blue States or do you think more
conservatives Republicans are leaving
blue States finding red states to go
to I think a little bit of both but I
think
that surely the the red states are the
ones that are growing uh you look at
there's a map that shows you where taxes
are taxes are going uh and they're going
to Red States uh I think people feel the
schools are better uh there's there's
less regulation uh lower cost of living
greater economic opportuni so I think
both both Republicans and Democrats are
leaving for those reasons I just think
that Democrats have not figured out that
there is a reason why these things are
are causing you to leave I I would I
would agree with that my independent
research would say it's probably seven
to three seven is the conservatives that
are so Tom's the fact check guy when you
say something is Mr Wikipedia what we
call very very impressive no seriously
oh well thank thank you very much uh my
my wife got out of college Cal State
Northridge and uh she started teaching
so she was at La unified which for other
people is a LGE is the largest school
district in the United States and it's
actually too Co too large to self-manage
and the teachers union there um very
very blue but very very upset and these
teachers have been leaving and they've
been going to Phoenix and they've been
going to Riverside even and out to to
areas where they feel that they can get
a that they can be a teacher with a
better cost of living and so my informal
analysis of it is I'm seeing 8 to2 or 7
to3 uh to your question I I agree it's a
little bit of both Tom I mentioned vosa
earlier the former mayor of of La when
he was run running the first time his
wife um is a is a um teacher at LUSD MH
and he was asked why don't you have your
own kids at La USD I remember this and
the wall in front of his house you're a
big proponent of of public schools you
oppose school choice and he said and I
quote I would never sacrifice my kid by
putting my kid in an LA USD School wow
but I'm running for mayor of this fine
City and he and he did not win because
of that comment wow well at least he was
being honest at least he's honest yeah
at least he's honest at least he's not
telling the and by the way it's so funny
you're saying this we're talking about
California I'm actually really curious
and the reason why I'm asking this
question is because which one is
outwardly blue but internally they feel
safer in the red state right because
think about it socialists feel safer in
a capitalistic Society right they don't
want to leave this place if you really
feel safer being in a socialist society
go to a socialist country why stay in
America so I think more red is willing
to leave Blue and I don't think blue
leaves red I think blue feels safer in
red while red doesn't feel safer in blue
because they're not welcomed I think
you're making it more complicated than I
think there just a lot of hypocrisy for
example uh there was a study some years
ago where uh government School teachers
that's a term I prefer instead of public
school government School teachers were
asked with school age kids were asked
where you put your own kids Nation why
10% of us have our kids in private
school 6% of black families do 49% of
Philadelphia Public School teachers with
school age kids have their own kids in
private schools 39% Chicago Public
School teachers with school H kids put
their own kids in private school the
head of the Chicago Teachers Union
recently said that school choice was
racist her own kid is in private
school I have a question just hypocrisy
let me stay on by the way rank hypocrisy
stats came up Ju Just to uh uh uh
Brandon and I were doing this video to
see during Co top 10 highest tax ta uh
tax stes and the bottom lowest tax stes
okay during coid the top 10 highest tax
states lost $341 billion of AGI okay tax
revenue the top 10 right lost 341 okay
guess what the bottom 10 lowest tax
states gained $341 billion did you
understand what just happened right
there it's a swap it's a swap it's like
you moved $341 billion of money under
management at Gold to Morgan Stanley
that's exactly what happen so Co was a
great case study for us to see what
works what doesn't work my concerned
right now with a state like California
do you think a
California uh uh how quickly do you
think a California could flip and if yes
what would be the reason for it to flip
if I knew the answer to that you'd be
talking to me from Sacramento I don't
know I I I I liken the average voter in
California to a drug addict you got to
hit rock bottom and start and start
rethinking your votes I've never been a
favor in favor of of term limits uh I'm
now in favor of term limits for voters
if you vote Democrat two or three times
you lose your right to vote I'm just
kidding I'm just
kidding you know I I just thought that
at some point even leftwing voters in
California would go you know what I I
got to go a different way but they
haven't when I was running a um the wife
of a retired mtown record Mogul uh she's
in her 80s he's in his 80s uh was
murdered he had armed security at his
house some guy who shouldn't have been
on the street one of these life lifelong
criminals broke into the house shot and
killed her uh a UCLA graduate student uh
was working at a high-end furniture
store in an area of La called Hancock
Park where Maxine Waters has her Mansion
she was stabbed to death by another
homeless guy and I thought maybe at this
point maybe some people in the left
might rethink their assumptions but they
haven't and Larry what what do you think
it is from from like all those cities is
it just the indoctrination is so wrong
like if you're living in Chicago
Baltimore New York San Francisco and
you're seeing everything is it just like
listen we're not going to admit that
this is we're going to stick with
it because Democrats they fall on the
sword they stay loyal to the partner
it's like no we're we're good I I I
think it's that it's indoctrination it's
it's that plus a belief Republicans are
just bad people you we just can't it's
not that we disagree about uh about
abortion about taxes about spending we
are bad people fundamentally bad people
they've convinced people that well this
goes back to something we talk about all
the time and that's you know why do
people vote do they vote for personality
or do they vote for policy I would argue
that it's overwhelmingly about
personality right so you could go the
policy argument all you want right taxes
regulation but if you don't have a
charismatic
candidate on the left on the right
running it like you're never going to
win it's just not going to happen people
vote on personality I I don't see it
that way I think people vote mostly on
what they perceive to be their best
interest uh often they're wrong about
that but they but they vote on what they
perceive to be in their best so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here